J'ai été au MIT pendant 44 ans. J'ai participé au premier TED.
Une seule autre personne ici, d'après moi, a fait cela.
A toutes les autres conférences TED -- et je suis allé à toutes, sous la direction de Ricky --
j'ai parlé de ce que faisait le Media Lab,
qui aujourd'hui compte presque 500 personnes.
Si vous lisez la presse, on y disait la semaine dernière que j'ai quitté le Media Lab.
Je ne l'ai pas quitté, j'ai démissionné du poste de président --
qui était un titre un peu ridicule, mais quelqu'un d'autre l'a depuis endossé,
et l'une des choses que vous pouvez faire en tant que professeur,
est de rester professeur.
Maintenant, et pour le reste de mes jours, je vais me consacrer au projet "One Laptop Per Child" (OLPC),
ce que je fais plus ou moins depuis un an et demi, de toute façon.
Je vais donc vous parler de cela,
utiliser mes 18 minutes pour vous dire pourquoi je fais ça,
comment nous nous y prenons, et ce que nous faisons.
A un moment je vais même faire circuler parmi vous
ce à quoi le portable à 100 dollars ressemblera peut-être.
Chris m'a demandé d'aborder quelques-unes des grandes questions,
j'ai donc imaginé commencer avec les trois qui m'ont poussé à faire ce projet.
La première est assez évidente.
C'est incroyable quand vous rencontrez un chef d'État, et que vous lui demandez,
"Quelle est votre ressource naturelle la plus précieuse?"
Sa première réponse ne sera pas "les enfants",
mais dès que vous le dites, ils sont plutôt rapidement d'accord avec vous.
Cela n'est donc pas très difficile.
Tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que quelles que soient les solutions aux grands problèmes,
elles incluent l'éducation, parfois uniquement l'éducation,
et qu'elles ne peuvent jamais être sans une composante éducative
C'est très certainement une partie de ma motivation.
La troisième raison est un peu moins évidente.
Chacun d'entre nous ici présent a appris à marcher, à parler,
non pas en recevant un enseignement sur la parole ou la marche
mais en interagissant avec le monde,
en obtenant certains résultats en retour de notre capacité à pouvoir demander quelque chose,
ou en étant capable de nous lever et de l'atteindre.
Alors que vers l'âge de six ans, on nous dit d'arrêter d'apprendre ainsi,
et on nous dit que tout savoir désormais viendra par l'enseignement,
que ce soit par quelqu'un debout, comme moi actuellement, ou un livre ou quelque chose de semblable.
Mais c'est toujours par l'enseignement.
L'un des apports des ordinateurs à l'enseignement
est qu'il comprend dorénavant une nouvelle forme d'apprentissage
qui ressemble plus à ceui qui nous a permis d'apprendre à marcher ou parler,
en ce que ce processus est piloté par la personne même qui apprend.
Alors avec tous ces principes --
quelques-uns d'entre vous connaissent peut-être Seymour Papert,
en 1982, lorsque nous travaillions au Sénégal.
Certaines personnes croient que le projet n'a démarré que l'année dernière,
ou il y a deux ans, ou que ça nous a pris tout d'un coup.
En fait, ce projet remonte à très loin, en fait aux années 60.
Ici nous sommes dans les années 80.
Steve Jobs nous avait donné quelques ordinateurs portables, nous étions au Sénégal.
Ce projet n'a pas grandi mais au moins avait apporté des ordinateurs à des pays en voie de développement,
et nous avions rapidement constaté que ces enfants --
même s'ils ne parlaient pas Anglais,
l'alphabet latin était à peine leur langue,
mais ils étaient comme des poissons dans l'eau;
ils pouvaient jouer sur ceux-ci comme sur des pianos.
Un peu plus récemment, je me suis impliqué personnellement.
J'ai deux anecdotes -- l'une au Cambodge,
dans un village qui n'a pas d'électricité, pas d'eau, pas de télé, pas de téléphone,
mais qui a maintenant un accès internet haut débit.
Pour ces enfants, leur premier mot en anglais est "Google,"
ils ne connaissent que Skype. Ils n'ont jamais entendu parler du téléphone.
Ils ne se servent que de Skype.
Ils rentrent chez eux le soir; ils ont une connexion haut débit
dans une hutte sans électricité.
Les parents adorent, parce que quand ils ouvrent leurs ordinateurs portables,
ils obtiennent la source lumineuse la plus puissante de la maison.
Voici un cas où les métaphores et la réalité se confondent --
ceci est l'école.
En parallèle, Seymour Papert a convaincu le gouverneur du Maine
de légiférer sur l'OLPC en 2002.
À l'époque, je pense qu'il aurait été juste de dire que 80% des profs étaient --
-- disons, réticents.
En fait, ils étaient contre.
Ils auraient préféré voir l'argent utilisé
pour payer des augmentations de salaire, plus d'écoles, quoi que ce soit.
Maintenant, trois ans et demi plus tard, devinez ce qui s'est passé?
Ils constatent cinq choses.
Une quasi disparition de l'absentéisme, la participation aux réunions parent-professeurs --
auxquelles personne n'allait, et auxquelles presque tout le monde assiste à présent --
une baisse des problèmes de discipline, une hausse de la participation des élèves.
Les profs disent maintenant qu'il est amusant d'enseigner;
les enfants sont attentifs. Ils ont des ordinateurs portables.
La cinquième, celle qui m'intéresse le plus,
est que les serveurs doivent parfois être éteints la nuit
parce que les enseignants reçoivent trop de mails
d'élèves qui posent des questions.
Quand vous voyez ce genre de choses, il est clair que nous n'avons plus à tester.
Les jours des projets pilotes sont révolus, lorsque les gens disaient,
"Bien, nous en voulons trois ou quatre mille dans notre pays pour voir comment ça marche."
Cassez-vous. Retournez dans la queue, quelqu'un le fera à votre place,
et vous pourrez aussi nous rejoindre quand vous aurez compris que ça marche.
C'est ce que nous faisons à présent.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Ainsi, OLPC a été créé il y a un an et demi.
C'est une association à but non-lucratif; elle a réuni à peu près 20 millions de dollars
pour concevoir la fabrication de cet appareil, et pour le produire par la suite.
Le volume est très important.
Pas parce que cela permet d'acheter des composants à plus bas prix, OK?
Mais parce que vous pouvez aller voir un fabricant --
que je ne nommerais pas --
nous voulions un petit écran, sans besoin d'un parfait rendu des couleurs,
un pixel ou deux pouvaient manquer, il n'avait pas besoin d'être aussi lumineux.
Le fabricant en question a dit: "Eh bien, vous savez,
cela ne nous intéresse pas. Ce qui nous intéresse, c'est la salle de séjour.
Ce qui nous intéresse, c'est un parfait rendu des couleurs.
de grands écrans, des écrans lumineux.
Vous ne collez avec notre stratégie."
Je leur ai dit: "Eh bien, c'est dommage,
parce que nous avons besoin 100 millions d'unités par an."
Ils ont dit alors, "Ah, bien, nous pourrions nous inclure dans votre stratégie."
Voilà pourquoi le volume est important.
Voilà pourquoi nous n'allons pas nous lancer sans envisager cinq ou dix millions d'appareils pour la première série.
L'idée est de débuter avec un volume suffisant
pour que le volume lui-même même réduise le coût,
et c'est pourquoi j'ai inscrit sept à dix millions ici.
Nous faisons cela sans équipe de vente ni de marketing.
En fait, l'équipe de vente et de marketing, c'est moi.
Nous y arriverons en nous allant dans sept grands pays, en obtenant leur accord et en lançant le projet.
Ensuite, d'autres pourront suivre.
Nous avons des partenaires; il n'est pas difficile de deviner que Google est l'un d'eux,
et les autres attendent toujours de voir ce qui se passe.
La presse s'intéresse beaucoup à nous.
Nous avons présenté cette fameuse "Machine Verte" avec Kofi Annan
en Novembre au Sommet Mondial qui se tenait en Tunisie.
Maintenant, quand les gens regardent ceci, ils disent, "ah, c'est un projet d'ordinateur portable".
Eh bien, non, ce n'est pas un projet d'ordinateur portable. C'est un projet éducatif.
Ce qui est amusant -- et je suis très concentré sur ce point --
je dis aux gens que j'étais auparavant une ampoule, que je suis à présent un laser.
Je vais bientôt réussir à faire construire cette chose,
et en fait ce n'est pas si difficile que ça.
Parce que la logique économique de l'ordinateur portable est la suivante:
J'ai écrit 50% ici; en fait c'est plutôt 60,
Le commercial, le marketing, la distribution et la marge représentent 60% du coût d'un ordinateur portable.
Nous n'avons aucune de ces choses.
Rien de cela ne figure dans nos coûts.
Parce que, tout d'abord, nous vendons à prix coûtant, puis le gouvernement le distribue.
L'appareil est distribué dans les écoles comme un livre d'école.
Donc, cette partie de l'équation disparaît, et ensuite vous avez l'écran et tout le reste.
L'écran de votre portable coûte, approximativement,
10$ par pouce sur la diagonale.
Vous pouvez le réduire à huit, même à sept,
mais il ne va pas tomber à deux, ou à un et demi,
à moins de faire quelque chose de très malin.
Le reste -- cette petite boîte marron -- c'est assez fascinant,
parce que le reste de votre ordinateur est dévoué à lui-même.
C'est un peu comme un obèse qui se voit obligé d'utiliser la plupart de
son énergie pour déplacer son poids.
Nous avons une situation aujourd'hui qui est incroyable.
D'accord, j'utilise des ordinateurs portables depuis leur apparition.
Et mon ordinateur portable est plus lent, moins fiable et moins agréable qu'il ne le fut jamais.
Cette année, c'est encore pire.
Maintenant les gens applaudissent, parfois il y a même qui se lèvent pour ovationner et je leur dis,
"qu'est-ce qui vous arrive? Pourquoi sommes-nous assis ici?"
Quelqu'un que je ne nommerais pas a dit récemment que notre ordinateur était un gadget.
Je lui ai répondu, bon Dieu, notre ordinateur portable va faire un malheur.
Quand vous l'ouvrez, il fera "bing" et sera allumé.
Ce sera comme en 1985, lorsque vous avez acheté un Apple Macintosh 512.
Il marchait très bien.
Depuis, nous n'avons fait que régresser.
Alors ça, tout le monde me demande ce que c'est.
C'est ça.
Il y a ici deux éléments remarquables : le réseau maillé :
lorsque les enfants ouvriront leurs ordinateurs portables, ils seront tous en réseau,
et n'auront besoin que d'un ou deux points de connexion.
Vous pouvez mettre un réseau à deux megabits pour quelques milliers d'enfants.
Alors vous pouvez vraiment faire entrer ça dans un village,
et les villages se connecteront eux-mêmes,
et vous pouvez faire marcher cela plutôt bien.
L'écran à deux éclairages -- l'idée est d'en avoir un écran qui marche aussi dehors --
n'est-ce pas amusant d'utiliser un téléphone portable sous le soleil?
Eh bien, vous ne voyez rien.
L'une des raisons est que le rétro-éclairage est tout le temps activé,
sur la plupart des téléphones portables.
Nous en avons fait un qui sera allumé à la fois par devant et par derrière.
Nous devons décider si le choix se fait via un interrupteur manuel ou par programme.
Mais quand c'est rétro-éclairé, c'est en couleur,
quand c'est par devant, c'est en noir et blanc avec une résolution trois fois supérieure.
Est-ce que tout a bien fonctionné? Non.
C'est pourquoi pas mal de nos équipes habitent plus ou moins à Taïwan.
Dans un mois environ, nous saurons si ceci marche ou pas.
Probablement, ce qui est le plus important
est que les enfants soient capables d'entretenir l'appareil eux-mêmes.
Ceci est à nouveau quelque chose que les gens ont du mal à croire,
mais c'est bien vrai.
C'est la machine que nous avons montrée à Tunis,
et c'est la direction que nous voulons suivre.
C'est quelque chose que nous ne croyions pas possible.
Maintenant, je vais faire passer ceci.
Ce n'est pas un simple concept.
C'est une concrétisation de génie mécanique que vous pouvez essayer.
Il est clair que ce n'est qu'une maquette.
Celui qui marche est au MIT.
Je vais le passer à ce beau jeune homme.
Au moins comme ça vous pouvez décider s'il va à gauche --
oh, diffusion simultanée. Désolé! J'ai oublié. OK, où que soit la caméra --
OK, bonne remarque. Merci, Chris.
L'idée était que ce ne serait pas seulement un ordinateur portable,
mais qu'il pouvait se transformer en livre électronique.
Donc c'est une espèce de livre électronique.
C'est comme ça que vous pouvez aller dehors, c'est en noir et blanc.
Les boutons de jeux ne sont pas là, mais ce sera aussi une console de jeux, une machine pour lire.
Mis comme ça c'est un appareil télé.
Etc, etc. -- est-ce que ça suffit comme ça pour la diffusion simultanée? D'accord, désolé.
Je vais laisser Jim décider où l'envoyer ensuite. OK
Sept pays. (Rires)
Je dis peut-être pour le Massachusetts, parce qu'ils doivent faire un appel d'offres.
C'est la loi, vous devez faire un appel d'offres, et tout ce qui s'ensuit.
Alors je ne devrais pas vraiment les citer.
Dans les autres cas, ils ne sont pas obligés de le faire. Ils ont juste à décider.
C'est le gouvernement fédéral à chaque fois.
C'est un peu stressant, parce que beaucoup de gens disent,
"Bon, faisons cela au niveau de l'état."
Parce que, bien sûr, les états sont plus flexibles que les autorités fédérales, à cause de leur taille.
Et nous comptons.
En fait nous avons vraiment affaire au gouvernement fédéral;
nous avons affaire aux ministères de l'éducation.
Si vous regardez les gouvernements autour du monde,
les ministères de l'éducation ont tendance à être les plus conservateurs,
même ceux qui ont un grand nombre de fonctionnaires.
Tout le monde croit savoir éduquer,
et il y a beaucoup de culture là-dedans aussi.
C'est très difficile. C'est certainement la voie la plus ardue.
Si vous regardez les pays, ils sont assez distribués, en termes géo-culturels.
Sont-ils tous d'accord? Non, pas tout à fait;
probablement la Thaïlande, le Brésil et le Nigeria sont les plus actifs,
et la plupart sont d'accord.
Nous ne signons intentionnellement avec personne
avant d'avoir des appareils qui marchent.
Comme je visite chacun de ces pays au moins tous les trois mois,
je fais le tour du monde toutes les trois semaines.
Voici en gros le planning,
j'ai mis en bas que peut-être nous en offrirons à TED dans deux ans.
Tout le monde dit, un ordinateur portable à 100$, vous ne pouvez pas le faire.
Eh bien, croyez-le, nous ne le faisons pas.
Nous allons commencer à 135 au début, et ensuite descendre.
Et c'est très important,
il y a tant de choses qui sont lancées à un certain prix qui ensuite augmente.
C'est un début à perte, et dès que ça décolle,
c'est trop cher, ou bien ne peut pas être fait en quantité.
Alors nous visons 50$ pour 2010.
Le marché gris est un grand problème. Et une des façons -- une seule --
une des façons d'aider en ce qui concerne le marché gris
est de faire quelque chose d'unique.
C'est un peu comme les voitures --
des milliers de voitures sont volées tous les jours aux États-Unis;
mais pas une seule voiture de facteur. Et pourquoi?
Parce qu'il n'y a pas de marché pour les voitures de facteur.
Elles ressemblent à des voitures de facteur.
Vous pouvez les peindre; vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous voulez.
Je viens de l'apprendre: en Afrique du Sud, personne ne vole les Volvos blanches.
Aucune. Jamais. Zéro.
Alors, nous voulons que ce soit comme une Volvo blanche.
Chaque gouvernement a un groupe de travail. Ceci est peut-être moins intéressant,
mais nous essayons de faire travailler les gouvernements ensemble, et ce n'est pas facile.
Les aspects économiques nous font commencer par les gouvernements fédéraux,
pour ensuite passer à autre --
-- que ce soit un financement enfant par enfant,
pour qu'un enfant dans ce pays en achète un pour un enfant dans un pays en voie de développement,
peut-être du même sexe et même age.
Un oncle en donne un à une nièce ou un neveu pour son anniversaire.
Je veux dire, toutes sortes de choses vont arriver.
Et ce sera très très intéressant à voir.
Et tout le monde dit -- je dis -- c'est un projet éducatif;
donnons-nous les logiciels?
La réponse est, le système comprend bien entendu des logiciels,
mais non, nous ne fournissons pas le contenu éducatif.
Cela se fera vraiment dans chaque pays.
Mais nous sommes des constructionnistes.
Nous croyons à l'apprentissage à travers la pratique,
et tout depuis Logo, qui commença en 1968,
jusqu'à des applications plus modernes comme Scratch, si vous la connaissez,
sont tout à fait dans cette idée.
Et c'est le lancement prévu.
Rêvons-nous? Est-ce réaliste? En fait, c'est la réalité.
La seule critique, et les gens n'aiment pas critiquer ceci,
parce que c'est un effort humanitaire, un effort sans but lucratif,
et le critiquer est un peu stupide, en fait. (Rires)
Mais la seule chose que les gens pourraient critiquer est,
"super idée, mais ces gens-là n'y arriveront pas."
Cela peut vouloir dire vous, profs etc, vous ne pouvez pas faire cela,
ou bien, ce n'est simplement pas possible.
Eh bien, le 12 Décembre, une entreprise nommée Quanta a accepté de le construire,
et comme ils font un tiers des ordinateurs portables sur terre aujourd'hui,
la question n'est plus posée.
Alors, la question n'est plus de savoir si ce sera fait, mais quand.
Et si ça coûte 138 dollars, qu'est-ce que ça peut bien faire?
Et si ça prend six mois de retard, qu'est-ce que ça peut bien faire?
C'est quand même pas mal. Merci.
(Applaudissements)